que benalla vous comprenez que vous me
dites qu'on a voulu faire les choses en
règle et la préfecture de police
énoncer des motivations qui permettait
au port d'armes d'être légal
tout à fait est ce qu'on ne peut pas en
déduire que si vous n'aviez pas eu la
mission de police relevé par le préfet
de police
mais si vous aviez fait la demande
uniquement en disant c'est pour ma
sécurité personnelle
normalement et légalement le permis de
port d'armes aurait dû vous être refusé
alors c'est pas tout à fait exact comme
il l'a été au ministère de l'intérieur à
deux reprises sur ce que je vais
repréciser encore il a été refusé à deux
reprises par le ministère de l'intérieur
sur des motifs administratifs sur des
problèmes non pas de deux d'opportunité
ou pas même si un moment sur le premier
port d'armes est intervenue une décision
de frédéric auréal chef du sdlp qui n'a
pas souhaité que je puisse porter une
arme pendant cette campagne
présidentielle sur le deuxième la
deuxième demande c'est un problème
purement administratif parce que je
n'avais pas renouveler en l'état en
faisant état de mes nouvelles fonctions
la demande et on avait relancé la
première demande